as we rounded from uh 2019 into 2020 uh
uh the CDC they all had counterparts in
China and they'd been talking because
there was this rumor about what was
going on there and right at the first of
the year total shutdown locked out I was
asked uh by uh Mr Redfield to call my
Chinese counterpart the foreign minister
and the state Council I did nothing not
a word the World Health Organization
gets shut out when they try to
investigate sadly they just bent a knee
and said nope everything nothing to see
here folks so the who failed the world
as well but yeah they went into complete
information lockdown uh hiding from the
world what they most certainly knew
about what had happened there
so you were Secretary of State during
covid and uh that kind of that kind of
changed the world can you talk about
that a little bit yeah
so a couple things one I ran a massive
Airline for a bunch of months we had
Americans stranded all over the world we
brought back a hundred thousand plus
Americans who'd had roadways buses
airplanes pulled out from under them and
so we went and tried to round them all
up which was amazing work the state
department actually I gave them full
credit for having managed this process
to help get these people back home out
of uh tough places but more broadly it
gave us two opportunities and a couple
challenges uh first challenge was look
this virus almost certainly came from
the Chinese lab and we were immediately
I think I said this on a TV show in
March of 20 uh maybe it's April and you
know just pillory
you know I was a a racist in the
anti-china racist nope it came from the
lab almost certainly also China Chinese
is not a race but that's a different
thing but okay no it's uh it's all crazy
yeah
but even more important than where it
came from the Chinese leadership knew
that they had a pretty damn contagious
relatively lethal virus on their hands
by the fall of 19.
and decided to put tens of thousands of
people on airplanes and murder and I say
that intentionally murder
hundreds of thousands of people all
across this country they had a choice to
make the choice they made was load
airplanes send them to Milan Italy
the Chinese Communist Party must be held
accountable for this look they don't
care about human life
so be it but when you when you transmit
that to the rest of the world and you
kill people all around the world there's
a place for real accountability
um the good news is I think Americans
came to see how bad the Chinese
Communist Party really was the risk to
America if we outsourced all of our
Manufacturing
certainly semiconductors and national
security stuff but think basic things
like simple Pharmaceuticals uh uh the
capacity for uh our medical system to
operate without Chinese Supply chains I
think American people can see that that
was a bad idea and those businesses are
starting to come back to America and to
places that we can count on to Partners
and friends and that is a good thing uh
the last thing was covet had the upshot
of giving parents a crack and a window
into what their kids were being taught
in schools and ain't no mama wants their
kid to be taught that America is a
racist nation and that Math and Science
and reading don't matter and I think
we've seen a fundamental transformation
about how parents think about public
education they want to make sure their
kids get a fair shot at the American
opportunity and I was all across the
country last year campaigning for
candidates it didn't go as well as I
would have hoped but I was out there
grinding away listening to folks and
they are serious about this and you know
the fact that we're all we were all
watching more closely what our kids were
up to I think is a net good thing for
America yeah and by the way it's
happening right now I mean Kim Reynolds
is doing school choice in Iowa uh
Huckabee's going to be doing it in
Arkansas clearly something's good you
know something Good's happening here in
Florida but on the first part of that
when when you guys realized that in
essence it was coming from China either
fully intentionally or not or then they
were sending these planes at first Italy
and then everywhere uh I'm guessing you
got on the phone with some sort of
Chinese counterpart I mean did they just
Stonewall you on everything did they
admit anything was there any level of
accountability or anything
total Stonewall I tell this story it's
an important story as we rounded from
2019 into 2020 uh
the CDC they all had counterparts in
China and they'd been talking because
there was this rumor about what was
going on there and right at the first of
the year total shutdown locked out I was
asked by Mr Redfield to call my Chinese
counterpart the foreign minister and the
state Council I did nothing not a word
the World Health Organization gets shut
out when they try to investigate sadly
they just bent a knee and said nope
everything nothing to see here folks so
the who failed the world as well but
yeah they went into complete information
locked down uh hiding from the world
what they most certainly knew about what
had happened there how do you as the
Secretary of State coordinate or work
with those you know the who the NIH the
CDC all of these things I mean you're
dealing with borders and planes and all
of that stuff are you directly telling
are they basically telling you you've
got to shut borders and you can't do
this you got to do that like who who's
actually in charge at that point yeah so
the senior decisions about what America
was going to do in the response made by
President Trump himself with the advice
from me and from the Department of
Defense from NIH to CDC all of his
advisors were around the vice president
led the response task force but in the
end the big decisions about whether to
close our Borders or not were made by
the president do you guys think you
botched anything I mean if you were to
look back the would you have done this
differently or that differently or
advised him differently or anything
you know I thought about this a lot uh
there in perfect hindsight you can see
that there was information we didn't
know or we weren't thinking about quite
right I think we got good pieces of the
actual physical response right but I
think we got some of the messaging wrong
and then as time moved on and more
information was available I think Dr
fauci uh did Terrible Things by talking
about this in a way that kept our
schools closed for as long as they did
we knew that the kids were unlikely to
have serious large-scale ramifications
from this
we we told teachers that you can stay
home when we told nurses they had to go
to work you know they're all important
uh but why on Earth we didn't open our
schools more quickly while we were so
closing that up and we had churches and
synagogues shut down too uh is
incomprehensible to me do you think it's
fair to say that China did this
intentionally maybe not the leak itself
but that the export of it and when
you're being stonewalled and all these
things that this was sort of the plan to
get Western democracies to in essence
turn against their people become a
little bit more like China rather than
China become a little bit more like us
which is what I think most people
thought was going to happen you know for
the last 30 years something like that
Dave Dave you you got it exactly right
yes absolutely intentional at the very
least we can argue knowing versus
intentional as absolutely knowingly uh
sent this virus around the world and I
from my perspective the difference
between knowing and intent is zero in
this case they intended this virus to go
around and they knew it was going to
kill people all across the globe uh you
know what what were there motives for
that we can all argue about I don't know
I don't know the answer but here's what
we know for sure a decent Nation a
nation that cared about Humanity would
have opened the doors brought in the
world's leading experts wouldn't have
let anybody travel would have locked
down that virus as best they could where
they found it and have given them the
global community and frankly it's
America mostly America's best scientists
the capacity to understand what was
going on there so that you can develop
solutions that actually make sense not
just for China but for the entire world
and they chose exactly the opposite
course so what do we do about that I
mean if if that actually is the case
let's say you were to have another job
in your future perhaps what do you do if
if that really is true
uh it's real uh don't don't kid yourself
about the World Health Organization
saving the lives of Americans they're
not going to you have to take this upon
ourselves we're happy to work with folks
around the world these these these kinds
of things are Global problems but
America is going to have to lead and we
can't do it by providing a bunch of
money to guys at the world health
organizations that don't really give a
darn about
um the second and third order
ramifications of their failures if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell